what's up reject nation greg and johnny
here
we're gonna watch this teaser trailer
that was only released on social media
for one division it's super duper short
of course want to check it out i hear
that the release date the official one
is featured in here i
know it's not 20 20. i've
heard for a while now that it was
supposed to be 2020. everyone thought it
would at least come out
after mandalorian maybe around christmas
time apparently that's not the case
let's see what's in store with this
little video and then uh
chit chat just for a tiny bit
oh the mood the mood
i want to stream it on old tube tv
[Applause]
january 15th that's not that far away
it's basically december
it's not bad it's still the winter time
i love the comics accurate costumes
oh the mood i kept saying mood because
you're looking at this imagery of like
classic 1950s type of television setting
with these beautiful images of them as a
happy couple
but it just feels like some dark sci-fi
trapping
that turned in throughout like
something's wrong don't believe the
pictures you're seeing
don't believe the imagery this is
actually really scary
i know some people are probably a little
bit hurt at the fact that it's not
coming out in 2020. it's kind of weird
to think about it there's been no
marvel thing not no marvel things in
2020 huh there's been nothing to marvel
at
that's pretty crazy yeah wow nothing mc
related but this is going to be the
official kickoff
for marvel phase four and that's why
they did it almost to be like you know
what let's just have it be a clean year
of no marvels and then we'll do
everything in 2021 that's fair i mean
you know they've had of course
certain issues with the world to deal
with that have affected filming
schedules and a whole bunch
more also this makes sense from a disney
plus standpoint
you know mandalorian runs i believe
until december 18th
the movie soul comes out on christmas
keep people hooked on january and then
for everyone who's like upset
that why is it not december darn it what
january
it's it's a couple weeks later you'll
have enough you'll still
have to watch in december right you can
wait two weeks until
january but i love the way this is
shaping out to be i can't wait for an
official trailer
what do you think about it coming out in
january is this date satisfactory for
you
it's official i mean it's not gonna mean
why would there be a delay yeah
six january movies now maybe this is
horrible news maybe they have no faith
in it
all right guys talk with you soon
subscribe click the notification bell
see you guys soon